Tony Stark may be gone, but his genius
lives on through Peter Parker's suit choices
in "Spider-Man: No Way Home." Peter sports
an outstanding number of Spider-Man suits
throughout the film's 148-minute runtime.
Some of them are fits fans have seen before,
and others are brand new to the
MCU. Here's a quick rundown.
WARNING. Major spoilers ahead.
"You ready?"
"I'm ready."
"No Way Home" begins right where 2019's
"Spider-Man: Far From Home" left off.
Mysterio's doctored footage revealing the true
identity of Spider-Man is released by The Daily
Bugle. Now, the whole world is against Peter
Parker and believes him to be a murderer. With
this turn of events, it's only appropriate that a
connection between the two films remains intact.
This connective tissue is the very first
suit we see Spider-Man wear in "No Way Home":
his upgraded Spider-Man suit. The outfit
we see in the first act of the movie is
the same one he creates on Tony Stark's
plane in "Far From Home" and proceeds to
wear in his final battle against Mysterio.
It's nice to see this earlier suit return,
especially considering we've only seen it in
one previous fight. For the most part, the
older suit remains in Peter's closet throughout
much of the runtime of "No Way Home." After the
opening sequence, Peter's in trouble with the
law, so he doesn't do a ton of crime fighting.
The suit featured most prominently in
the marketing materials for "No Way Home"
is the Iron Spider suit, also known as the Iron
Spider Armor. This is what Peter Parker wears
during one of his battles against Doc Ock.
The Iron Spider suit is made up of nanotech,
enveloping Peter right when he needs protection,
and boy, does he need it against the Doc.
At one point during their fight, the scientist
takes a blade out from one of his tentacles.
Right when it's about to pierce
Spider-Man's exposed chest,
the nanoparticles shift position
from his face to his chest,
protecting him from the attack while revealing
his identity to the multiversal villain.
That's not the only significant development
provided by the nanotech. Otto Octavius
absorbs some of the particles into
his tentacles, providing them with a
red tint featured throughout the trailers.
Peter's able to use this to his advantage,
and since he has access to Tony Stark's tech,
he's able to manipulate the tentacles to do his
bidding. It ends the fight and allows him to
bring Otto into Doctor Strange's holding cell.
When the first trailers for "No Way Home" were
released, there was a lot of speculation about
what the black and gold suit would do. Was it
specifically designed to withstand attacks from
Electro? As it turns out, it's simply Peter
Parker's upgraded suit turned inside out.
Earlier in the film, we see Peter get green
paint thrown on him. Plenty of New Yorkers
believe The Daily Bugle's propaganda that he's
responsible for Mysterio's death. With no way to
prove his innocence, Peter has to put up with
various assaults, including being doused with
paint while wearing his Spider-Man outfit.
He doesn't have time to get it cleaned, and,
always wanting to look fresh, he turns it inside
out to deal with the next interdimensional threat.
As it turns out, he looks pretty slick
in the new Spider-threads with the
prominent black fabric and gold accents.
Shortly after his battle with Electro,
Peter gets the suit cleaned, but
it looks great in the moment.
NEXT up: This gold-trimmed suit is one
of the most highly anticipated Spidey
suits fans have been waiting to see in
action. The design was initially teased
as part of a toy leak for "No Way
Home," and now that the movie's out,
audiences can see what the so-called "Iron
Spider Integration Suit" is all about.
This shiny suit gives Peter the much-needed
boost in power he needs to take on all of
these previously-seen Spider-Man villains. And
surprisingly, it's actually in the movie for quite
a while. The suit first makes an appearance when
Spidey and friends are at Happy Hogan's condo.
He then takes the suit with him to the
final battle at the Statue of Liberty,
where he stands out compared to the suits worn by
Andrew Garfield and Tobey Maguire's Spider-Men.
Yep, Garfield and Maguire both turn up in "No
Way Home." Merry Christmas, True Believers!
"Egg-shell-see-or!"
And finally … "No Way Home" has what
might just be the most devastating ending
of any MCU film so far. Before more
bad guys can break into their universe,
Peter Parker has Doctor Strange perform a spell
to make the world forget that Peter Parker
exists, but still remember
that there is a Spider-Man.
As a result, M.J., Ned, and Happy will
lose all of their memories of him.
It's a poignant moment and one that exemplifies
what the Spider-Man persona is all about. His
entire philosophy centers around sacrificing what
he truly wants for the betterment of the world.
The last time we see Peter, he has his own
apartment and is studying for the G.E.D.
However, he hasn't hung up his Spider-Man
suit just yet. He may no longer have
access to all of Tony's gear, but he's
pretty proficient with a sewing machine.
The last sequence sees him jumping out
of his apartment window wearing a new,
homemade suit he designed. We can't show it here,
but he's stuck with the red and blue palette from
previous costumes, and it looks like he'll be
on his own in any future franchise installments.
Hey, the title wasn't lying when it
said there was "no way home" for Peter.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus, even more
Looper videos about "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.